je préparais trouvera sa place est-ce
que ça désaveu au nom il n'empêche que
cet acte et nous ferons tout dans la
bataille dans le combat pour les
intérêts du marin maintenant je ne suis
pas à faire une guerre de personnes et
je réitère justement cet appel à tous
pour la sérénité la solidarité et puis
qu'on se fasse confiance et voilà le
combat on me dit sera difficile je le
crois on y est maintenant c'est c'est
tout tout était un objectif est d'aller
dans l'intérêt du marin on sait bien que
je sais désormais à des velléités qu'il
veut se présenter
comment vous allez faire est ce qu'il ya
une entente possible et comment vous
allez gérer
non je crois qu'à un certain stade il
faut pas se leurrer on n'est pas non
plus dans un monde de bisounours comme
on dit non c'est clair démocratie et
dans tout ce qu'ils voudront se
présenter se présenteront et puis bien
évidemment tous ceux qui voudront venir
travailler avec nous nous en discuterons
ensemble parce qu'il ya un groupe aussi
qui travaillent avec moi et au delà de
monsieur le maire il ya un groupe qui
travaillent à mes côtés et nous
déciderons ensemble voilà mais il
n'empêche que bonds qui voudra venir
que ça soit le deuxième adjoint lequel
le quatrième enfin peu importe c'est
comme ça est ce que cette division ne
risque pas de vous faire perdre que la
commune se sont enfuis à ce qu écouter
les cils et voilà on nous avons décidé
d'y aller nous irons combat je vais me
défendre
bec et ongles afin que justement nous
puissions continuer avec les équipes il
ya bien évidemment du personnel dans
cette mairie qui travaillent qui a vécu
beaucoup de difficultés aussi dans la
progression que nous avons eues au marin
le but c'est que nous puissions
continuer ensemble maintenant les
divisions je pense qu'à un certain
moment
6 les divisions stériles basé sur la
méchanceté ne mène jamais très loin ça
fait très mal mais ça ne mène jamais
très loin si le cas avec je sais
pourquoi vous parler spécifiquement de
lui vous savez il ya peut-être pire a
que lui je sais pas mais en tout cas les
coups bas sont présents donc je ne sais
pas s'ils viennent spécifiquement de lui
ou pas je vous trouve donc votre propre
camp il ya des coups bas
il ya des coups bas en règle générale ça
veut dire peut-être que ces personnes là
n'ont jamais été dans mon camp comme
vous dites dans une majorité peut-être
mais pas dans mon camp vous avez votre
carte au ppm je crois que vous n'avez
pas vous tromper vous savez jamais quand
la forme que vous je n'ai pas
l'intention aujourd'hui je parle bien
aujourd'hui de prendre de 40 et je n'ai
aucun problème avec le ppm en tant que
tel là le marin aujourd'hui moi jeune
femme arrivant j'ai 50 ans quand même
donc je reste quand même une jeune femme
arrivant je suis arrivé en politique en
2008 pour travailler parce que je
sentais que j'étais capable de faire
quelque chose voilà pour ma ville je les
fais je suis pas arrivé je suis pas
arrivé là en tant que politicienne et
j'ai fait de mon mieux
nous avons eu des réussites avec les
collègues jeudi les collègues
en tout cas les équipes municipales
qu'elles soient administratives ou
techniques
aujourd'hui se pose la question du parti
pas partie je pense que c'était aux
municipales a besoin d'eux que ma
candidature et besoin d'eux a besoin de
soutien bien évidemment mais
prendre une carte de parenty là ce n'est
pas ce n'est pas utile pour le moment
ceci étant au marin à prendre l'exemple
de monsieur le maire il a quand bien
même ils étaient où il est au ppm il a
toujours travaillé avec tout le monde
dès lors que c'était en faveur du marin
on vous dit qu'on vous dit proche quand
même de la république en marche
alors je me suis un certain moment posé
la question de savoir est ce qu on reste
quand même sur des modèles anciens
je vous dis je suis arrivé je pars le
travail en tant que jeune femme chef
d'entreprise
pour moi il y avait quand même des
questions sur si on veut faire du social
il faut qu'on puisse accompagner le
développement économique est aujourd'hui
penser que du social penser que
entreprises il fallait ce lien et je
m'étais dit que il fallait qu'on ait un
nouveau modèle les modèles existants ne
me convenait pas et que si on donnait un
grand coup de pied dans la fourmilière
peut-être que tout le monde réagir et
voilà donc c'est vrai que
j'ai voilà j'ai travaillé en ce sens
pour les présidentielles je n'ai pas
pris je ne suis pas membre de la
république en marche mais il n'empêche
que sur le marin quand je vois le
travail qui a été fait le développement
économique a permis effectivement que le
social soit une réalité il ne peut pas
vous n'êtes pas en marche vous n'êtes
pas nous éloigner non plus de la
république en marche vous avez obtenu le
soutien de max orville du modèle très
proche d'omar ben vous voyez que le
marin c'est une terre ouverte
et puis que nous ne sommes pas figés
dans un modèle c'est peut-être ce que de
jeunes élus comme moi-même devons mettre
en place certainement au lieu de rentrer
dans des clivages qui ne nous concerne
plus elle a maintenant dépassé donc le
modèle actuel pas de clivage je ne dis
pas qu'il n'y a pas de clivage mais que
moi j'arrive en tant que jeune
politicienne et que je rentre dans un
monde de moselle déjà qui ne me convient
pas mais où je vais arriver avec des
rivalités qui date de 30 ans de 40 ans
je dis que ce n'est pas mon combat je
dis que je ne suis venu venger personnes
mais en tout cas pour mes enfants pour
mes parents et tous les autres je pense
qu'il est temps que nous mêmes jeunes
politiciens que nous puissions regarder
l'avenir d'une autre manière
la mise en examen de rodolphe désiré
dans la sphère carré nantis constitue un
vrai cailloux quand même dans votre
d'autres dont vos chaussures combien de
cailloux et pour avancer
non ce n'est pas ce n'est pas un caillou
c'est c'est bon on les dit comme ça
c'est une difficulté supplémentaire
c'est peut-être aussi le moyen de mettre
les choses à plat
il n'empêche qu'aujourd'hui il faut bien
faire la différence nous avons au marin
plusieurs activités sur ce plan d'eau
avec bien une zone technique qui
s'appelle le carénage
nous avons un port de pêche où nous
avons une zone plage activités de
loisirs nautiques
nous avons un port de plaisance tout ça
est à gérer et nous avons aujourd'hui
une autre zone 95 hectares
supplémentaires
où nous devons faire l'aménagement et
organiser des zones de mouillage
nous avons des interlocuteurs nombreux
nos villes il faut qu'on nous
travaillons avec tous puisque ce sont
des outils qui publie qu'un des
délégations de service public ça reste
propriété publique donc de la ville du
marin et des marinois et bien évidemment
on peut pas arriver dans des
concurrences donc dire qu'il ya un autre
port de plaisance qui s'écriaient c'est
quand même un peu bête puisque ça nous
appartient donc mettre en concurrence
deux entités voilà et puis quand on sait
que ce qui est le nautisme
on a besoin de zones d'amarrage on a
besoin de zone de réparation on a besoin
de zones de navigation etc
donc on aura certainement l'occasion
d'en reparler mais non la difficulté est
là et pour avoir travailler justement
dans ce domaine depuis que je suis
arrivé en 2008 pour ces projets là la
tâche n'est pas facile au quotidien et
il faut essayer de mettre tout à plat
aussi avec les professionnels mais c'est
quand même une mise en examen lourdes
les les accusations sont fortes
il faudra convaincre mais même aller au
delà quant à lui fait parce que là vous
allez traîner tout le bilan est tout ce
qui s'est passé vous n'êtes pas porter
ce fardeau sur vos épaules mais c'est
mon choix de porter ce fardeau parce que
sinon j'aurais déjà fui depuis très
longtemps un même avant cette mise en
examen
la tâche est très difficile enfin on
sait tous que plus on développe plus
nous avons des interlocuteurs nombreux
et différents plus les difficultés se
posent elles se posent sur
l'organisation des entreprises sur notre
territoire
elle se pose aussi sur l'aménagement de
notre territoire elle se pose surtout ce
qui est circulation sur notre territoire
et c'est vrai que c'est c'est une très
lourde charge liée au complot pour
atteindre rodolphe désiré par ricochet
vous même alors on va dire que dans deux
affaires un peu différente parce que moi
j'ai été attaqué aussi un
professionnellement et bon c'est une
affaire qui certainement va rebondir
puisque on est en période politique et
que au moment de la ctm
c'est arrivé bon voila nous monsieur le
maire se défendra et apportera les
preuves et moi de mon côté pour ce qui
me concerne je continuerai aussi à me
défendre apporter les preuves
oui c'est vrai qu'en 2015 vous avez
connu des difficultés et ça vous a
d'ailleurs coûté votre place sur la
liste dans une martinique nouvelle wii
alors ça m'a coûté ma place en fait on
va dire que à la limite aujourd'hui avec
du recul je me dis que c'était
effectivement une catastrophe qui aurait
fait que fait que je ne puisse pas être
sur la liste de la cités m
j'ai fait ce choix de me retirer
j'aurais pu rester j'ai fait ce choix
quand même accepté de me retirer parce
que je me suis dit que voilà le marin
n'avait pas besoin de tant d'histoires
et puis maintenant même si ça revient
dans dira que pour moi c'est le bon
moment en tout cas de rester accrochés à
cette envie et à ce devoir de continuer
le travail aux marins vous savez que
vous êtes sur les réseaux sociaux vous
savez que lis que dis-je à ressortir de
vieilles affaires des affaires datant de
2 98 de l'eau dtm commence se départir
de tout ça quand vous faites garder la
tête froide
prendre de la hauteur de la profondeur
est allé très loin donc ce qui veut dire
oui à des réseaux sociaux
bien des personnes qui parlent ya des
coups de fil il ya plein de choses qui
se passent mais il faut toujours viser
la cible
la cible ce sont ces élections la cible
c'est garder le niveau de compétence du
marin au bénéfice des marinois mais au
bénéfice aussi des martiniquais et puis
de se dire que voilà c'est une mission
qu'on s'est donné
c'est un choix personnel que j'ai pris
et que mes enfants acceptent ma famille
accepte et voilà on ira jusqu'au bout
maintenant s'il est question d'avoir
peur au temps à sécher soit je ne reste
pas chez moi avec toutes ces turbulences
comment qu'est ce qui vous pousse encore
à vous présenter d'autant plus
qu'aujourd'hui être maire c'est
quasiment une coquille vide
on voit que tous les pouvoirs ont été
transférés aux le pci
oui mais quand on est maire on a la
possibilité effectivement de siéger dans
les ep seuil et donc c'est de travailler
ensemble
ceci étant le combat il part du terrain
donc travailler ensemble c'est vrai qu'à
des habilitations aux communautés
d'agglomération qui pose problème mais
quand on parle justement de tout ce qui
est érosion donc la fameuse gema pis si
nous ne travaillons pas ensemble nous
n'y arriverons pas donc tout c'est vrai
que c'est une difficulté mais il
n'empêche que voilà je suis convaincu
qu'il faille aller ils volent triste je
vous remercie bonne journée l écoute de
nos programmes
merci à tous et bonne journée
[Musique]